here with reaction Senate candidate
Kelly Chewbacca I actually called the
Lisa murkowski and come and see
protection ranking system of voting am I
wrong on that
you're absolutely correct Sean this was
put in place by murkowski's allies and
her campaign staff it was exposed in
Undercover videos so we know that the
system was rigged in her favor but it is
a great honor and I'm very humbled at
this point that alaskans have voted for
me to have the lead in this race over a
21-year incumbent that sides with Joe
Biden and the D.C establishment against
the interests of alaskans it's clear
that alaskans have gotten that message
through we have definite uphill battle
and I'm honored to have their support
it'll be great to get to D.C and to and
to support them in that way
so there was another Republican in on
the ballot that bowed out and endorsed
you I think that candidate got what
close to three percent of the votes
somewhere around there
he has about three percent of the vote
and again we still aren't even through
round one yet so we don't have the final
tally of where our our totals sit this
is going to be a lengthy process and we
need to make sure that there aren't any
games played through the ranked Choice
scenario we need resources for ballot
observers people can help me at
kellyforak.com hopefully when we get to
the level two when his ballots drop off
we're hoping to pick up as many of these
second place votes as possible we have a
strong Pathway to Victory still so you
have then the the next candidate the one
that will be eliminated is a Democrat
that got 10 percent of the vote now
correctly if I'm wrong I think Lisa
murkowski votes with Joe Biden what 67
percent of the time
that's correct she mostly votes Democrat
she supported all of his judges and his
radical environmentalist nominees that
have hurt Alaska but remember these
Democrats that voted the Democrat first
these might be your principal Democrats
who aren't going to vote for a
republican because we saw in the primary
and again in the general
yeah
she votes she votes with the Democrats
so in all likelihood a high percentage
of her ten percent of the vote the
Democratic candidate that's getting out
in ranked Choice voting I doubt they're
going to vote for you because you are a
real conservative and they'll end up
voting for Lisa murkowski and that to me
is unfair to the people of Alaska that
gave you the most votes on Election Day
this is how the system is like we said
rig twin murkowski's favor but those
Democrats also might not vote for
anybody second place that's also an
option they could just be Party Line
Democrats who don't want any Republican
at all one of the questions that came up
in the debate from the Democrat
candidate from murkowski was she
supports limits on abortions and she
supported all of the justices that
overturned Roe versus Wade that's one of
the things Democrats up here are mad
about so we don't know what's sitting
behind candidate three and four we still
have a strong Pathway to Victory I love
the state of Alaska I love the rugged
individualism of the people of Alaska
but this system you all have in Alaska
is probably the dumbest system I've ever
seen across the country
I suggest strongly that you change it
because otherwise this will continue
it's crazy Kelly Chewbacca good luck as
this process continues hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else